this show exists
also obvious hey we know this show takes
place after the zombie apocalypse but
we're starting it with zombies so you
know there will still be zombies in this
show
opening scene is obvious this outlining
feature kind of makes this look like
eduard moons the scream
except this painting would be called the
i'm bored already it was a nightmare all
along cliche
my sister throws this big feast day
ranger every year tomorrow night
10 p.m storage room c12 nothing says
awesome rager like being crammed in a
small storage room with a bunch of drunk
teenagers
there sure were a lot of people right
around this bus departure for no one to
have seen the stowaway
uh stowing
even if huck couldn't hit all three of
them with her jeep which she absolutely
could why wouldn't she at least try to
take out the two that were together
no no no i don't know what happened yeah
me either was it originally just
the civic republic part and then a bunch
of blank space what did you even think
it was going to say
also these two shades of blue are too
similar to put right next to each other
in a banner that is supposed to be this
colorful and it happens four times
it's called the pursuit of excellence
hope lieutenant colonel elizabeth
kublick of the civic republic military
ah sudden guinevere also a civic
republic lieutenant colonel with a
british accent
not in my america i mean not in my civic
republic military
crm crm people call me huck
long story well go ahead and tell it if
the walking dead universe was concerned
about taking too long to tell a story
this show wouldn't have ever even seen
the light of day
[Applause]
considering you had to either cut or
fold this to make your oh so clever
adjustment earlier shouldn't we at least
see a crease here
why don't you draw in paint drawing and
painting won't put an end to reanimated
necrotic matter what about putting an
end to this tedious and completely
uninteresting five-minute conversation
between characters you're desperately
hoping i care about will drawing and
painting put an end to this because i
can find a paintbrush
real fast representatives from our home
city of omaha
and the alliance cities of portland and
the civic republic
is that the start of a narration as
bookends to the pilot episode cliche i
hear
careful with the young cast the ominous
authority figures in the trendy music
your one character takes off a piece of
clothing for no reason away from this
being cw's the walking
dead happy feast day people i'm not sure
i'd go with feast for any title of a
celebratory day that came after the
zombie apocalypse pretty sure a lot of
these people's close relatives were
feasted upon by walkers
so that seems a a little on the nose and
be gross
also i get that the walking dead is an
insanely successful franchise but was a
teenaged angst version of the show
something people were clamoring for
don't we already kind of have that with
riverdale
those actors are playing zombies on that
show right i was just assuming they were
based on all the dead expressions they
give in their performances
let me ask you something why do you do
what you do
when you have what you have man this
character exposition request is so
self-serious enforced that after he
dramatically put his back to her and
dramatically turned his head
he might as well have dramatically said
tell me hope what do you really want the
audience to know about you before the
end of the first episode
you are a family member dad gave you
guardianship while he's gone
this super convoluted and might i say
insanely boring long-winded sequence
only serves the purpose of allowing the
audience to find out that felix is iris
and hope's legal guardian and you might
say well
felix being their legal guardian is an
important part of the story and you
would be wrong
you know what i'm good i don't need to
listen to those craps
my reaction 10 seconds into every
conversation in this show
somehow makes it into the script that's
why i come here and come here for the
team
get it like the gossip all the kids are
saying it we're totally cool like that
although considering that phrase wasn't
around when the zompocalypse started
would slang have still progressed the
same way it's not like
we've never talked about it talked about
what
oh you know tell me like i don't you
know just in case the audience wants to
know too
iris i think you're dreaming you're dead
because you are neglecting
you you are not dating yes because
dating is how you determine whether or
not you're a normal person
i'd be checking dr k's therapy
credentials right about now your head
is shoved so far up the future's ass
you've completely
abandoned the now the mcu even if i
could have
and make the wine you serve the time
rhyming wine with time
it's not even about the empties i mean
it is but
it's about the people people are it
might be ten years later but we're
somehow still on this the walking dead
is really the people and not the zombies
train that was irritating before season
one of the original series even ended
also we went from walkers to empties
when
and why is that really the only thing
that will differentiate this show from
the original in fear because so far that
appears to be the case
it ain't it is what it is well now i'm
just confused because i thought it
is it is what it is but if you're saying
it isn't then i guess maybe it is it
isn't it is what it is
so thanks for clarifying also what kind
of advice is that
huck is like the mike brady of the
walking dead universe
episode does not contain a karate fight
with zombies dragging this flashback out
is such an indictment of what the
walking dead represents that i'm almost
willing to remove a sin for the simple
fact that we do get a resolution to it
at the end of the episode i said almost
oh i didn't we were just uh we're at the
janitor's office and saw you walk by and
also like
we came here together because um i think
we're supposed to maybe be like main
characters or something so
we needed to see this elton found an
easy bake oven
we made cake even in the midst of a
zombie apocalypse i would choose
starvation
over eating the cardboard weaponry that
an easy bake oven shoots out
safety isn't assured she says loudly in
front of the exact same classmates she
just admonished her sister for having
the cabinet open in front of if
painting empties helps dr babbler study
their migration patterns
why are you studying migration patterns
of zombies sorry
empties instead of just disposing of
them all if you have the zombies
sorry empties contained just in them now
right this would be like having a
vaccine to an awful disease but then not
having your children vaccinated
can you imagine you're missing you can
say
the only regret i have about saying skip
right now is that i didn't do it when
this scene started what seems like 20
minutes
ago so skeep
he's breaking like 10 provisions with
four corners agreement by even sending
us these messages
we knew that before he left we talked
about it great so
why are you talking about it again here
i get this is for the audience's benefit
but it makes zero sense they would be
talking about all this right now
they would be trying to decipher the
message and trying to figure out what to
do about it
92 percent of this episode is on
creative exposition dumps
we don't know if he's in trouble except
he sent a message saying he wasn't safe
so
i'm thinking you absolutely know he's in
trouble character motivations in this
series are insane
my safety not assured that's what it
said but it's letters
and numbers it could be radio static
what they are bad people iris and they
have our dad are you talking about us
yes they are how convenient that you
just happen to be taking a stroll after
dark by this very spot
and that makes me brave
we have to be brave roll double
commercials
your father is teaching in a civic
republic
research facility in new york state this
is a
coded map so it doesn't show you where
in new york
so really i've given you zero reason to
believe me at all but i'm hoping you
will take this maybe grab a couple of
your friends and attempt to hike 1100
miles to new york so you'll be gone when
my soldiers and i destroy this colony
and kill all of your friends and
neighbors we
cool you're brave sorry roll triple
commercials
it's bad yeah you sure it wasn't just
radio static
so you have all your firms situated with
iron doors to keep them from escaping
after death but no other life protocols
that would keep a visitor from
accidentally opening up a zombie room
cameras check-ins a simple medical
bracelet that checks for a pulse
also no reason to check on the girl on
the floor who might be hurt or in shock
let's make sure we focus our attention
on the contained zombie who can't hurt
anyone currently
representatives from our man just when
you think this show couldn't get any
more trophy dopey they pull out the
classic bit where the protagonist had a
prepared speech but decides to wing it
as a way to show how they are growing
and changing
this is some top-notch troping going on
here today honestly we should all be
very impressed
so we go just us if things were like
before this would still be crazy
what is up with hope she was just
telling huck the day before that she was
probably leaving the colony soon because
she didn't want to wait till she was
older or dead and couldn't
now they received not one but two
distressed messages from their father
and she's in the it's all cool let's
just
chill phase now what the [ __ ] is this
show i froze that night
but i'm not freezing anymore are we in
the midst of yet another inspirational
moment monologue
the dialogue in this show is so earnest
i'm surprised it hasn't gone to camp
jail and saved christmas
you know what i mean vern when we get
there what are we gonna when we get
there
we'll be different
so how do you know where to go elizabeth
gave us a map to try and get us to trust
her
right so the person you don't trust gave
you a map you do trust
because it was a sign of supposed trust
from a person you still don't actually
trust
nope no holes in that logic carry on
you're gonna go
all that way great question one of the
two guys who are all the sudden central
characters even though they have a
combined total of four minutes of force
screen time between them the entire
episode
great question indeed it's a a horn
from a triceratops it's mine that's what
i've been going outside the walls
looking for
and you just happen to find it tonight
in the dark i would send the coincidence
but
i haven't seen the tuffy stitch suit
elton wears yet so let's just send that
instead
so elton's mom is the pregnant woman
that hope apparently killed after she
killed hope's mom
imagine if this was a good show and how
great this reveal would have been then
here it's just a little too late
we can't find her good wait that's it
50 minutes of four self-serious dialogue
to set up characters i still don't
really care about for
that measly payoff oh i get it this
whole show is a metaphor for how the
walking dead itself is now a zombie
plotting along with no purpose
brutalizing people who come in contact
with it and decaying until someone
finally puts it out of its misery
it's genius
three horns never play with long necks
people be like i is there a comment on
the video when it's just posted
fans be like i'm a member motherfu you
can be a [ __ ] member too get
videos early extra videos bonus podcasts
swag discounts and more click the
patreon link in the description or at
cinemasins.com to take your sin to the
next level
put on your sunday best kids we're going
to sears wait
sucks her ass you never go ass to mouth
i also hope to be much much taller i
wish i was the baller
we lost her because the sky was falling
the sky is falling are you crazy
it's about the people people are
people turn
it's just the odds and maybe arms be
ever in your favor i graduated
it's over i did it i know most of you
are saying
hey any idiot could do that well
it was tough for me so back off
it's a a horn from a triceratops
it's mine